so I denied being an active organizer of
this workshop and but two of the active
organizers Jon and Adam approached me to
give this prospective talk and coming
from a theoretical computer science
point of view and as you see from the
title and not that sure that I'll be
able to deliver that it's not clear that
this is a perspective or maybe these are
men's perspectives and it's not clear
that you will come in so they got to
pure scientists after this talk but
let's see so this is not going to be a
tutorial nor is it going to be a survey
and certainly not the historic survey
this is not my goal I'll tell you about
my golden minutes so a few
considerations in preparing this talk
one is that as Adam mentioned we invited
quite a diverse audience for this
program and for this workshop and this
is for purpose we believe that this is
the right thing to do and although this
is a center for Theoretical computer
science for illegal computer science at
least in some areas needs to communicate
with other very different areas of
research like law and ethics of course
statistics and so on so one of my goals
is to give some background and and
establish some vocabulary so that
hopefully we share some ideas or you
understand at least what we from the
theoretical computer science community
were trying to do some of the time and
as the basis for our discussions another
consideration is that certainly our
questions that I'm bothered about and
I'll speak about a few of them here and
maybe the third the most important
consideration was that I know that Kunal
is going to be giving much better talk
after I finish so I can allow myself to
do something what an oddly shaped
perspective here
okay so if there are questions please do
ask so Kunal you have you have a big
task you see and the layout for this
talk is gonna have three not equally
sized parts the first one is going to
focus on differential privacy and how we
get how we got there and why and here
really my goal is to establish some
joint vocabulary and begin discussion of
path forward which I think are going to
be very important for day for the entire
semester again this may look that I'm
serving some history and so on but think
about it really as like a way to explain
why we are doing some things the way
we're doing them and as a seed for our
forward discussions then I'll very
briefly cover some thing that bothers me
and this is a question of bridging
between legal technical concepts of
privacy so this is one potential path
forward and then I'll have some
concluding thoughts and this is going to
be quite a short part of the talk and
the goal is maybe this would be like a
starting point for a working group
throughout the semester okay so let's
begin so this entire semester is going
to talk about we're going to talk about
data privacy or something else sometimes
called informational privacy more
broadly and the problem is the following
we collect a lot of data not me
personally but there are organizations
who do that and this data can have very
good users if we analyze it so we want
to push that data into a process that I
will call an analysis or computation or
mechanism I'm going to use these terms
interchangeably and that thing at least
in the naive in the simplest case will
output some outcome that is going to be
useful hopefully for scientific findings
or policy making and things like
that and our goal is given a data set
with sensitive personal information
because this is often a collection of
information about individuals how to
compute and release functions of this
information while protecting individual
privacy let's remember this slide and
before I will go on with what the talker
wants to play a small game let's try to
test our intuition with respect to this
problem now I'm very bad at doing that
so if you don't guess it right feel good
about it you can it's okay and I had
about five or six challenges initially
which for the because of time limits I
will reduce to two now but let's suppose
that and the question is when is
information privacy preserved okay so
suppose that something like this happens
there is data pushed in the computation
and an outcome is produced and I'm
worried the worst I'm worried is it
because my record is in there in the
data set
okay so there is something about me
would may be sensitive information maybe
it turns whether I am a theoretical
computer scientist or not which is it's
quite an embarrassing trait I think and
let's assume that the outcome is indeed
Kobe is DCS positive now I'm looking at
this in my asking is my privacy breached
it looks like the simplest question to
be asked here who thinks fears
so things know who doesn't think who
thinks we cannot tell still see some
people who you know think the man but
maybe counter-intuitively if you haven't
seen this before that's the right answer
we cannot tell and the reason is that
yeah it could be that the computation
actually takes the input and the input
says copy as a teaser is positive and
outputs that and copy is that into that
output but we could also think about
other computations that could have taken
place in particular in the following one
so the timing language I know is basic
as you see so this is a very simple
basic program you output copy if this is
positive you know your data and that's
it okay
and I would claim that maybe this is
something that I will be disturbed about
or maybe there is like an issue for a
deformation claim or something like that
but this program does not create any
informational relationship between my
information in the dáil set and the
outcome and hence there's no way that
information is leaked about me through
this program okay so it's really
important to look at the computation
itself let's see just a second a example
let's say the same thing happens except
that the outcome is that Adam is this is
positive and I'm not mentioned in the
output okay who thinks this is this
would breach my privacy or thinks it
will not be to breach my promising
somebody here what's that you will
volunteer to think this way and who
thinks you cannot tell us it is a very
trained audience yes and again the
reason is similar because if this is the
simple basic program that is implemented
here it tests what I'm to say is
positive if yes it outputs Adam it is
this is positive otherwise it outputs
John is he said does not actually look
at the Adams information he his purpose
is not necessarily is intact here but
mine could be influenced okay so again
we cannot tell and the lesson I want to
take from this is that is very important
to look at the computation and not to be
tempted just to look at what the outcome
tells us which is unfortunately what
happened probably in a lot of the
privacy literature for quite a few
decades
I want to speak about defining privacy
and let me begin with an example that is
predates I think the work most of the
work order to work in theoretical
computer science and privacy is an
example from the Latanya Sweeney from
2000 where she I'm sure you've seen this
latter I will go very fast through them
but she took an anonymized data set with
patient information from Massachusetts
okay and this is this is part of a
record from that they were said so it
has all these maybe interesting features
on the left and then also a zip code
birth date and sex of that individual
and then she combined that with another
data set the voter registration from
Cambridge which is public records
anybody can expect them and
interestingly these records also they
they are not only identified soon we
have the name and address here and they
also have the zip birth date and sex and
she joined these two datasets okay and
when this join creates a unique
combination she could deduce the
identity of that person who was
supposedly anonymized okay and in
particular she identified these guys in
record and she put it in an envelope and
sanity to his address and furthermore
swinging and in what would Sumati they
suggested a privacy concept a new
privacy concept which is called Karen
limiting tournament e is designed
specifically to fall that linkage attack
okay and it is achieved via suppression
of information in the desert in order to
make every combination
or potentially identifiable at
identifying attributes appear at least K
Tong so the problem they thought was
that these combinations many of these
combinations were unique and then you
had a clear identification of record
maybe it will make sure that these
combinations these linkages are not
unique will gain tribes in here's an
example of how this is done on the left
you have like the original data set of
course it's a fake data set and the to
anonymize data set is on the right and
you can check that after the suppression
of information indeed the the
identifying information the left part of
the table each row appears at least
twice okay and you would think this is a
nice and they're very intuitive and has
been made to a lot of used like one
example is a team at Harvard used Karen
emitting I think would K equals
something between six and ten to
anonymize addicts data in 2015 smart
people do this also and we'll get back
to this later on
so this was one attack and it led to a
new privacy concept and I want to for a
minute
focus on this term a privacy concept we
should be careful in using it I want to
say and we should clarify too and self
what we mean by privacy concept when we
say a privacy concept and I'll get back
to this again and again in the talk okay
so is this a good privacy concept is
this a private concept these are
questions that I'm interested in let me
mention another attacked is what I hear
a teen or in myself and
it began work in what is called now
we're construction attacks also called
the blatant non privacy and consider a
system were sensitive information like
what we have here on the left about n
people installed ok for instance for
each person you stole whether they are
TCS positive or not and then the system
answers are statistical course ok and
this is really nice because if you have
such a system then researchers can ask
queries and get answers for this course
and hopefully do something about this
disease of people being Theseus positive
and that would be a positive outcome for
for this maybe maybe there is a cure
let's also assume that we have a
guaranteed accuracy and the accuracy is
better than root and so if they the
researcher specifies a subset of the
population that's for statistical query
and as how many people in this subset of
the population are to cs+
then the answer is not necessarily the
given answer is not necessarily accurate
it is within something like root in from
the true answer ok and we're not
specifying how this noise is added maybe
it's bias maybe it's not biased I have
no clue the only thing we know is that
the noise is bounded by very good
so now let's replace this good
researcher guy with somebody else
let's replace it with an attacker okay
is that attacking the attacker now you
use this in order to do something bad
now maybe you'd think intuitively we're
only asking you know aggregate queries
here and noise is okay it's not not
trivial
maybe it's impossible for the attacker
to do something but but actually there
exists in a fattier algorithm that
usually utilizes these queries doesn't
need to make too many queries something
that is linear in the size of database
and actually and then perform a physical
computation meaning that this is not
like factoring numbers or or solving
crypto problems this is something that
can be done in reasonable time and then
reconstruct the day said maybe not with
a hundred percent accuracy but let's say
99 percent accuracy so the attacker
produces this there are certain data
prime which is very very similar to
origin the original one okay
and actually the attacker can be
successful with like a more catered
algorithm even if many of the queries
are answered arbitrarily this is what my
working title wore and then there are
many other works following the
followed-up producing similar results in
in various settings an attacker that
gets access to our specific
functionality maybe even with some noise
or like within accuracy can use that
access in order to reconstruct database
almost perfectly okay from years this
have been theoretical results and and I
think many practitioners looked at them
and said oh this is only theory it
doesn't have anything to
say about real life but actually attacks
do work in practice and in the last year
alone the Cohen and myself we responded
to a challenge that was put right by a
company where cloak and used this kind
of attacks in order to show a weakness
in the system that day that they
presented that we could actually
reconstruct the data very accurately but
I think much more importantly is worked
at the US Census has been doing in the
last year and that has reported on
recently that they can take the 2010
decennial census tables that are were
published in the previous decennial
census and use these tables and this is
like a lot of information like what a
few numbers published for every
individual who participated in the
decennial census in order to reconstruct
the data quite accurately and not only
the US Census could do that actually a
reporter Hanson reported in the New York
Times that they probably did something
similar in terms of technique to what
the US Census were doing and they
reconstructed the information for I
believe for Manhattan so these are
things that not only very professional
people can do or like also people
outside the center's could access the
information and and reconstruct it and
what's interesting is that these very
strong attacks now become a tool for
we're thinking privacy and privacy
policy because if if it is visible to
reconstruct the data then either privacy
is completely lost or you are quite
close to to that happening
and that was not the only these are not
the only two examples of how a question
let's do so I need to recall that
so the original reconstruction attacks
just say like the data is is is is a
vector of bits for each person whether
or not their prime is also a sequence of
n bits and when you compare these
sequences they agree on 99 percent of
the cases okay and no matter what the
original data was how its created
whether it comes from an underlying
distribution or is it arbitrarily chosen
this reconstruction guarantee will hold
so that's that's the meaning for in the
original in like the sequence of papers
that were construction this is how this
is should be interpreted in in this
actual attacks design this was an
implementation of a similar situation
again the data we considered it as a
sequence of bits and I don't remember
exactly the numbers there is a report we
have a report but I think like we
managed to reconstruct with accuracy in
96 percent or something like that the
census data and they use different
techniques from from our techniques for
construction and essentially what you
want to find is a data set that agrees
with the publications that are that were
made public okay so if you take that
data set you could generate these
publications from it if that data set is
unique then you will uniquely recover
the data okay if there are some
potential underlying data sets that all
give the same tabulations then it may be
that you haven't uniquely recovered the
data but still you're likely to recover
the information of a lot of individuals
now if I remember correctly for the 2010
for this work by the census but we will
need to check it out what I think for
about half the u.s. population they got
the exact values that were put in the
tables and then for a large majority of
the of the rest and then the the main
errors were with respect to only almost
with respect to H and this world within
a few years span from the from the right
age and even those were in many cases
explained by the procedures that in some
places in the u.s. they first-round ages
to multiple of five and only then they
used it in the operation and then this
loss of accuracy can explain like the
two or three year difference they did
not identify that information which is
another step that needs to be taken
maybe to convince I mean I am convinced
that this is a privacy problem but maybe
others will need to actually see the
very notification personally I believe
that once you have reconstructed that
this level of accuracy then where denta
fication should be a feasible step but
we still need to see if this would
happen
so maybe one line summer is what I've
only said what you're looking you you
need an algorithm that will find a data
a data set that is consistent with all
the evidence that you see that you see
with all the publication's okay I don't
want to get into the details of the
particular thing
[Music]
so what it may be just a presumption
good point good point so I definitely
there are attacks were somebody
infiltrates the sensors or my computer
and and gets direct access to the data
I'm not going to talk about these
attacks I'm going to think about the
world where security researchers know
what they're doing and hence the only
way to attack these data sets is via the
legitimate interface so here I define an
interface what the attacker can make
statistical person get answers to the
statistical queries in the sentence case
the interface is all the list of
the large amount of tables that they've
published in the 2010 decennial census
I'm not assuming that the attacker can
actually infiltrate the center's
computers and get the data from there
okay let me continue so this these two
attacks are not unique like in the last
twenty years we've seen a lot of
failures of traditional personal
techniques and this is a partial list in
it that you can probably read you cannot
probably read and you could think that
we lost privacy but maybe we can get
privacy to rise from the ashes and let
me stay safe few reasons for optimism
this sofa it looks like quite a bleak
picture or like if we've seen it in 2003
2002 that is a bleak picture so I think
one reason for optimism and one
explanation why this work a lot of this
work came from people who had background
in cryptography
the initial work is that when we look at
what happened in cryptography there has
been a revolution in the in the late 70s
ok and photography turned from something
like an art to a science an extra
rigorous science where we have security
definitions and we have rigorous
analysis and we have proofs of security
okay things that we did not have before
and this has transformed cryptography in
the way that cryptography is rarely the
cause of a security flaw if at all if at
all so going back to your question yeah
even though we have cryptography we
still have security flaws but then the
problem is not where the cryptographic
interface of cryptographic protocols
usually but with other aspects of the of
the system and more importantly maybe
this research has yielded tons of
relevant influential concept I will just
mention two of them for this note one is
the notion of semantic security how do
you define the security of an encryption
scheme okay it has been a powerful
paradigm that has been explored for I
don't know 30 or 40 years by by
cryptographers and by the time we got to
it it was quite mature and ripe to to to
be grabbed and to continue with this and
the second thing that was cryptographers
have looked at is this notion of
composition what happens if you design a
secure system that is secure if it's the
only thing that is executing in the
world if you have two of these systems
running in parallel do you still have
security if you have your system that is
secure in the standalone manner is it
still secure when it runs in the context
of other systems okay in distance to be
an extremely complicated and intricate
question but again it set the ground for
our thinking when we start thinking
about privacy it was clear that it's not
enough to do to build privacy citizens
that are secure or that are prior
it in a standalone manner you need to
think about composition okay so by 2003
or two the research was in privacy was
at large ad hoc and it lacked regard and
coming again from a theoretical point of
view disregard in the interaction
respect was in many in many ways in it
like triggering setting clear meaningful
privacy goals so privacy was not defined
it lacked rigor in analyzing the
resilience not only to existing attacks
but to future attacks something that you
may think it's impossible to do but
cryptographer have managed to do it in
cryptography is the reason we won't be
able to do it in privacy it like trigger
in taking our knowledge into account in
accounting for privacy loss across
multiple releases in understanding how
the techniques the ideas that were
presented communicate with normative and
legal and ethical conceptions of privacy
and these are things that we need to
take to take care of so can we apply the
crypto we go to data privacy and this is
interesting
like maybe learning from crypto again
there is a power in negative thinking
okay that has played a crucial role in
in the privacy work I think in the last
15 years and in particular beginning
with the reconstruction attack you can
think about them not only as a bad thing
but as a useful tool because
reconstruction attacks help you
delineate or map the boundaries to what
cannot be computed while respecting any
reasonable notion of privacy so even
before you define privacy you learn you
can learn a lot about privacy from
reconstruction attacks maybe pictorially
you can think about it this way if this
is the map of the land of analysis or
something like that there is an area
that is blocked to us because if you
want that utility the
we can divide the construction attacks
okay and what is the privacy land is
somewhere here I don't know yet exactly
where maybe this is the boundary maybe
this is the boundary okay and what's
interesting here is that maybe there are
points where they can actually the
transformation from reconstruction to
privacy is like a phase shift and so we
are a would privacy getting the most
that is possible clearly it cannot be
this okay because if we want that
utility in this area this allows a
construction
and indeed a new line of privacy work
began initial works with a written
oriented work there was a privacy
definition and a Gaussian mechanism what
we now call the Gaussian mechanism the
semantics of the definition weren't very
well understood then it felt kind of
right but and composition wasn't well
inserted the words work from the
database community on the local model
some more work later on on how to do
private statistics in machine learning
and the beginning of an understanding of
this definition via a notion that is
called informed adversary that luckily
we don't have to use anymore
and later on this led so here I'm going
very fast about this probably like what
is that four or five years of thinking
about definitions led to differential
privacy in 2006 and this came also with
a beautiful paper by it worked my
internship working money no when they
made a case for differential privacy
explaining why this approach is very
plausible of what this approaches is it
makes sense so let me tell you about
differential privacy little but probably
most of you have heard this all try to
go very fast yes Adam you can just do
something else now because you know what
differential privacy is and differential
privacy is not a particular technical
part a particular mechanism this is like
if if you think about differential
privacy as a tool you're thinking about
it in the wrong way okay it's not a
particular technique it's not a
particular mechanism it's a definition
or if you wish a standard of privacy
okay and this is the standard or more
precisely it's a family of definitions
but I will treat them because they are
quite similar I'll treat them as a
one-two finish in here it expresses a
very specific disease rota of an
analysis so the focus is on the
computation not the outcome
as we've seen in the first couple of
examples this is this important and this
is the desiderata we require that any
information related risk to a person
should not change significantly as a
result of that person's information
being included or not included in an
analysis okay and this is a mouthful let
me now try to explain it with a picture
so consider two was in the real world we
have and by the way this is also
paradigm that is board from a
cryptography in the real world data is
fed into analysis and outcome is
produced yes this could be interactive
but I'm going to just for simplicity
look at this picture and again you
remember my data my record is in that
dataset so I'm worried that too much
information will be about me could be
leaked through the analysis into the
outcome okay this is my warning I'm
thinking about an ideal world or if you
were a counterfactual this does not
happen in reality but I am thinking
about a world world the same happens
just the data which is fair to the
analysis does not include my information
okay now in the ideal world I feel
secure there's no way that the analysis
will take mine on existing data in the
data set and if you do something that is
related to it in the outcome okay now if
in the real world and the idea what the
output would be sustained in or
indistinguishable and then I would feel
that since my privacy is preserved in
the idea world it's also preserved in my
real world okay so this thinking with
the counterfactual they're going to be
very useful for us
so that's initial intuitively what I'd
like to happen okay but if you analyze
this closely and you require that the
outcomes are indistinguishable then this
means that the analysis must ignore my
data my record
there's okay and maybe that's not that
bad because ignoring one record in the
data set often does not change the
utility in a very significant way but
then Adam comes and he's also worried
about his privacy
his record is in the desert and with the
same kind of analysis and the argument
analysis needs also to ignore his record
in the desert and Katrina also wants
privacy we need to ignore her data and
then actually want to provide privacy
for everybody in the desert even John so
we have to completely ignore the dare
set and that's bad for utility this
hasn't been that successful but maybe
maybe we can backtrack a little and
instead of having this very strict
requirement that the outcomes are
indistinguishable all the same let's
allow some slack Nestor liked the
outcome or similar and we need to be
careful in change in choosing this
notion of similarity and but when we do
that it turns out we don't have to throw
away the data and we get differential
privacy this notion of similarity is
chosen so that the chance of every event
is almost the same in my ideal and real
world and I'll give a few examples in a
few minutes absolutely the number okay
and the smaller absent is the better
privacy you get but then you are also
losing in utility if epsilon0 were back
to to the situation where work were
perfect indistinguishability between the
outcomes and hence no utility
so I'm sure canal will speak more better
definition I'm not going to parse this I
just want to say we can write it in in
math and the focus is on the mechanism
or the computation on the analysis it's
not on the output unlike anonymity in
other in other approaches
so this gives us new privacy concepts so
this is the land of differential privacy
actually it's a Confederate there are
many small differential privacy's
variants of the definition but again and
as you see in the picture in some places
we know that it actually gets what we're
getting the most that we can from
different from in terms of utility
because it touches their construction
land in other areas we don't yet know
and maybe there is another concept that
lies there and makes sense and we
haven't discovered it yet or another
time yeah that's also a concept okay
again I'm saying these are new privacy
concepts I want to be careful in using
the term privacy concept and you may say
okay people have tried it before how do
you know that this is a good price
definition this probably was thought and
let me try to to refer to this so what
makes a good privacy concept and and I
will go through a few properties that I
think are important first say it several
times so it's okay to say me one more
time it's a property of the computation
of the outcome okay so shifting from the
intuitive view that we should look at
the outcome of the analysis like let's
look at the anonymize they're set
although kernel image residents
something like that to looking at the
computation itself okay because the
computation is the entity that can
create this informational relationship
between the sensitive input in the
outcome okay and this relationship is
not understood if you look solely at the
outcome okay so that's really important
second property this is should be a
privacy concept so I think probably the
concept should allow us to make
statements on informational homes
otherwise maybe it's a concept but not
directly related to privacy okay and let
me give you a flavor of this such
statements and this will also refer to
what is like the the probability of
every event in differential privacy
should remain the same whether I
contribute my data or not okay in
differential privacy if the analysis
differential profit and the probability
that I will be now put whatever you want
to put there I'll be arrested or I'll be
denied insurance I'll be shamed socially
the probability that this will happen
will be almost the same whether my
information is used in the analysis or
it's not so this is this is what I call
a guarantee that is related to the
privacy so there is this is something
that depends on the information and the
information that I I have all
contributed to the data and this could
be a result of somebody looking at the
data and other stuff in ways that I
don't understand sorry in ways that I
don't understand but still differential
privacy gives me a guarantee that a
harmful event will not change its
probability significantly and I want to
say I'm saying half harm for an event
it's not a differential privacy
distinguishes between good and bad
events all events get the same treatment
but many times when we speak about
privacy were worried about the harmful
events not about the good ones the good
ones should also not lose in probability
to significantly yes you had a question
[Music]
so yeah so definitely when you can
reconstruct the data this is a very
strong signal that this is no different
that you cannot do something with
differential privacy the mechanisms for
differential privacy are mechanisms of
noise addition but you need to add the
noise in a very careful way this is one
thing and interactive mechanism often
will have to stop at some point and say
we're not answering any more queries
otherwise the privacy guarantees are
going to be breached now if you look at
concepts that simply limit the format of
the output we don't have these kind of
guarantees and in particular this
generates like kind of a pain treat and
pat cycle for instance like in the
traditional techniques we start with the
a notification improved it to calamity
and then people found witnesses there
and proved it to L diversity t closeness
and I'm sure this is not the end of the
list we have some more letters in the
alphabet okay a third property that also
leads to is composition okay consider
two or more independent mechanisms okay
maybe each of them satisfies the privacy
concept requirements but when you put
them together then and consider the case
where they process information about the
same or related population is privacy
still present when you put them together
where you consider them together with
the fascial privacy we have theorems
what strong theorems showing the
the combination of differentially
private computations result also in
differential privacy the parameter has
changed so if we begin with epsilon then
we'll end up with a larger epsilon but
this in a sense is essential because any
computation that makes useful makes use
of the data click some information so
these leakages are accumulated this is a
combinate combination of computations or
a combination of the data
these are combinations of computations
on maybe related data sets okay
relate so if you're still having so two
data sets that are different maybe they
both contain records about me
and again comparing with our calamity
it's conceivable that the composition of
k2k anonymize datasets which is all fit
many individual being anonymous actually
we it's very easy to come up with
examples where this happens but they are
not very natural maybe but you know it's
conceivable that the EDX data that was
published by the Harvard thing actually
if you compose that with itself then
privacy would be breached okay under
some notion of conceivable fourth
property is would like the notion to to
be quantifiable we if we are losing
privacy every time we would produce
something interesting with our data want
to be able to quantify that qualify the
accumulation and so on okay and an
important thing to remember is there
cannot be used indefinitely when new
insights are learned from the Dare set
then leakage also occurs okay and hence
the privacy risks grow and we need to be
able to we need some calculus to to
analyze the resulting privacy okay so
and we need to budget privacy laws and
we need to quantify the use of privacy
and if you ignore to do that is you
might as well know remove the fuel gauge
from your motorcycle and run
indefinitely without having to refuel it
okay it makes the same sense
with differential privacy the parameter
epsilon measures leakage can be related
to privacy harms and so on and can be
treated us like a privacy budget and
which is consumed as analysis are
performed okay and we have theorems that
have managed this budget by providing
bound on the overall use of the privacy
budget I want to say that we are not
there yet in terms of understanding how
to use these tools in real life how to
manage how to set up the privacy budget
how to manage it and there are many
interesting social questions with
respect to this because once you
understand that privacy is a resource
that is consumable resource okay and if
you consume too much of it then you lose
it then you have to think of how you
allocate that resource among tasks and
users and so on the questions that we
don't yet understand and the fifth fifth
principle I wanted to mention here with
respect to the privacy concept is
transparency it's much better if it's
not necessary to maintain the algorithm
or parameters secret when you use a
privacy concept and the benefits of
transparency and again this is a lesson
that we learned from cryptography using
cryptography cryptanalysis the
Scientific American scrutiny screw can
have a good screening of the of
mechanisms and furthermore analyzer
statisticians can use take that
knowledge they can understand how noise
is added into the computation take that
into consideration so we will also get
better utility and with the future
privacy you can allow full transparency
you can virtually reveal your mechanism
and the parameter is everything except
for the randomness and in contrast there
are some traditional techniques for
instance the swapping that is the
technique that is used by the year
sentence
and here security if at all exist there
then it relies on secret algorithms or
secret parameters that's a point where I
can skip things because of time let me
go very quickly on how differential
privacy is achieved because there was
also a question here we add noise as as
we do here differentially private
computations introduce random noise in
the computation the simplest ways to do
that is to a denies the noise on the
input level or the output level more
sophisticated to have emergent like
since the introduction of differential
privacy where noise is added in very
crucial points during the computation
many times this gives us much better
utility just I will not get into the
technical details I'm sure we'll hear a
lot of these examples in the more
technical talks let me just give like in
pictures like this is a fabricated data
set and which we reconstructed so this
is the cumulative distribution function
of the distribution and we estimated it
with differential privacy with various
values of epsilon you see if epsilon is
very small we're getting a noisy version
of off of the curve and then this is a
larger epsilon this it's it's a better
approximation this is even a better
epsilon a larger epsilon not better in
terms of privacy and so on and by now we
have tons of things that can be computed
with differential privacy including
descriptive statistics and supervised
and unsupervised machine learning tasks
some of which you will hear about in
canal stock and general research
generation of synthetic data and many
other applications
one thing to remember is because of
noise addition and differentially
private algorithms work best when the
data sets are large and so if you have a
small data set then slightly that the
application of different that
differentially private computations are
not going to give you good utility would
that data set what's not what is
differential privacy give us it would be
a mistake to think that if computation
is done with the fresher privacy and my
data is there then that my information
is kept secret okay actually
stigmatizing information information
that can help manipulate me things like
that could be learned about me with
differential privacy okay but this would
be the case when they could be learned
even if my information was not included
in the data set there's only things like
that there's a question to be discussed
whether this is a problem what this is
the privacy problem and I'm not going to
answer this people answer this question
in different ways another thing to
remember is differential pipe is not
applicable in settings where somebody
needs to actually operate on your
specific information for instance when
an ad is tailored to you or a news
article things like that we don't have
good privacy notions for these settings
it would be interesting to see if we can
develop them so maybe this could also be
part of discussions in this in this
workshop
and I think thanks to the theoretical
treatment of foundations of progress in
differential privacy we see that this
helps us build relationship with many
areas of research this is one benefit I
think great benefit of day to a real
computer science approach and in some of
these I overhear cryptography databases
complexity theory learning online
algorithms providing full discovery
mechanism design priming languages
policy regulation implementing
differential privacy notions like
fairness interestingly some of these are
two non where some of these are places
were differential privacy this concept
is used for non privacy reasons and in
particular in these three areas like
using it construction on algorithms in
preventing for discovery mechanism
design and we'll hear about some of
these in during the week some existing
applications like this is an old one by
day by now it's all by the Census Bureau
the only map application Google had
implemented in different professional
public computations and assistance for
telemetry
it's called rapport Apple is using
differential private computations since
I was 10 and there are also some
academic projects like this one is the
privacy tooth project at Harvard some
challenges it's a new concept and one
question is how to communicate it
strengths and limitations beyond the
computer science community ok how do we
develop that language that allows others
to operate on all these ideas and what
are the right use cases for implementing
differentially puppet computations at
this stage there is the challenge that I
mentioned about setting the privacy
budget and there is an important for
policy question here with respect to how
do you choose the privacy budget that
parameter epsilon how do you allocate it
among tasks and there's the question of
matching ratings with privacy law and
regulations so here I'm I ended the
first part of the talk which it's a good
time to get the perspective on the
perspective I guess and what's nice
about the perspective of it lets you set
back relax reflect on the load path that
you have taken since you started this
world and how far you got from the
starting point okay something like in
this picture and you may be returned to
maybe we're back in the initial point
that we were at and hence you may
remember this slide I'm showing it again
and to remind us that the what we're
talking about is this problem given a
data set with sensitive personal
information how to compute and release
function of the diversity while
protecting individual privacy okay and
kind of we gave one answer to this
question what does this actually mean
okay protecting individual privacy but I
want to get back to this question and
try maybe try again
so here think about in this hopefully
this will happen a lot of computer
scientists legal scholar will meet at
the Symons Institute and they will talk
about privacy and then probably we'll
get to some issues for instance they
would use the same words but the
meanings are going to be incompatible
okay what is it I mean when you say
privacy or linkage or things like that
they would use different reasonings and
they will pursue different values and
goals okay and a question is what we can
do some work in order to bridge these
different views so what does protecting
individual privacy mean and we've seen I
talked a lot about the TCS approach okay
it's rooted in complexity theory in
cryptography it advocates generality and
mathematical rigor and it generated many
interesting concepts like reconstruction
attacks differential privacy composition
that I mentioned privacy budget and some
other things that I did not have time to
to mention these are concept that were
born during this technical analysis of
privacy if you look at other areas like
the law then different answers are going
to be given to to this question of what
is protecting individual privacy mean
okay in the legal approach I have to say
I'm not well versed in the legal
approach one may be somewhat
misrepresenting it here this is my view
of the legal approach privacy and this
the answer to this question is specified
in regulations and these answers are
given with varying levels of specificity
in accuracy some examples of the
regulations in the u.s. is the Family
Educational Rights and Privacy
Act which deals with the educational
records HIPPA Health Insurance
Portability and Accountability which has
in it a privacy standard with respect to
health records title 13 which is the law
that refers to the work of the US Census
and they have a very short paragraph
about the private in the sense of
obligation to keep information that is
collected confidential in the youb we
all heard about the GDP are the general
data protection regulation that has come
into effect in the last year and maybe
one difference between the EU and the US
attempts are that in the in the US I'm
sorry there is there are quite a few
regulations that talk about privacy and
they're very sector specific and when
you look at some of them you see that
they don't really they sometimes they
verge on how to describe the privacy the
the diverge on the approaches that they
take on the level of on the number of
details that they give and so on and in
the U at least now we seen attempt to
generalize this in into one regulation
some inconsistencies and Australia t and
these are documented and written about
in legal scholarship and if you look at
these you see that there are also
there's also a collection of recurring
concepts which are different from those
that we had in the vertical computer
science analysis maybe the most
prominent in the legal writing is this
notion of personally identifiable
information variants on on this concept
but then also ideas like gamification
and animation
which are which refer to specific
families of tools or approaches to
provide privacy notions like link
ability when people speak about
assessing whether attacks like Sweeney's
attack are possible notion like singling
out that I will speak about in a few
minutes
appears in the gdpr inference
informational risk statistical purposes
the idea of opting out concerned and
some more in some more concepts and
these are quite different languages and
you could ask whether we can bridge
these very different languages and in
like a few questions that can be asked
about this as what are these
expectations that I expressed in the law
are they're reasonable and other I think
attainable or maybe we can we should
modify them a little to adjust them to
our current scientific and understanding
of informational privacy on the other
way you could look at this this is looks
very far from something that a lawyer or
an ethicist would write and you could
ask whether this technical concept match
the legal owner normative understanding
of privacy now we're talking about
something similar we're talking about
the same thing okay or are we solving a
different problem when we are coming
with with this approach so I want to
speak briefly about some ideas here this
is part of the project that we've been
running the beginning with with a group
at Harvard in about five years ago and
initial work that we had focused on this
standard on FERPA and tried to see if we
can make it claim the differential
privacy the use of
refresher privacy when I say that I mean
the use of differential profit
techniques whether that satisfies the
legal requirements that infer par for
protection of educational records and
I'm I'll be very happy to speak about
that but I chose not to spend too much
time there and speak about part of a
newer work when we look at the concept
that is taken from the GD P R and try to
see whether we can figure it out
starting from the legal text and going
into more technical analysis of this
concept and again I'm going to go over
this quite briefly I believe there's
going to be there will be a talk about
this in one of the upcoming workshops so
what is singling out when you look at
the gdpr it's quite a monumental
document and it's composed of articles
and recycles if I understand correctly
and I'm not sure I do the articles are
more operative and the recitals are more
helping understand some of the concepts
although I've seen that this is not
always the case when you read the text
in the first article in the gdpr tells
us what this regulation is about they
say this regulation lays down rules
relating to the protection of natural
persons with regard to the processing of
personal data okay way to read this if
what you have is data about natural
person and if this is personal data then
there are all these rules in the gdpr
that you now have to be a world and make
sure that you're that you another way a
way to accept yourself from the
requirements of the GD P R is to stop
working with personal data make sure
that the ear data is not personal data
now in article four personal data is
defined and they say personal data means
any information relating to an
identified or identifiable natural
person an identifiable natural person is
one who can be identified directly or
indirectly okay it seems a bit circular
but but it tells us that like one word
what's important in personal data is the
facts that it contains yeah
information about natural persons and
furthermore that information could be
identified if the information cannot be
identified then we were fine in the
sense that we can accept ourselves from
from the requirement of the gdpr okay
and later on and we started 26 I think
this is fascinating text by the way it's
really interesting to look at this this
legal standard in result 26 they say to
determine what a natural person is
identifiable account should be taken of
all the means reasonably likely to be
used such as singling out so identify
the natural person directly or
indirectly by the way after singling out
they don't give another example so
that's the only example of what it means
what it could mean mean that a person is
identified if that person is singled out
okay
in the earlier data protection directive
singling out is mention along wise with
wood linkage and inference so they have
a slightly longer list of things that
couldn't go wrong but in the GDP our
thinking out is the only one that is
explicitly mentioned and you would hope
to do a controller from the GDP our
search for singling out and find an
exercycle
recital that defines it but
unfortunately this term appears only
once only once in there in the standard
so what can you do now luckily the DPD
Data Protection Directive they set up a
working party it's called the article 29
working party that produced a collection
of documents that explain virus terms
virus ideas from from the Data
Protection Directive okay and in
particular there is a document it's the
article 29 working party opinion on an
image on anonymization techniques and
it's an interesting document that
reviews this concept of singling out
link ability and inference they try to
explain them and they also review a
collection of technologies and try to
assess which technology solves which
each which issue ok and when they speak
about single you know they say has
regard directly identified or
identifiable persons this category
typically relates to the phenomenon of
unique combinations whether small or
large in size a name itself may not be a
name itself is not less may not be
necessary in all cases to identify an
individual this may happen when other
identifiers are used to single someone
out ok and in the red text is of course
my highlight and this is the table that
the
these guys provide you see there is a
collection of what they call on musician
techniques for which they ask is it
still singing out still a risk is linked
ability still a risk is influenced in
arrays can you see that whereas the
fresher privacy is here and they say to
the question is single out still a risk
they say may not okay figured that in
your mind what that means and for
anonymity and diversity they say Oh
finding out is not risk anymore
okay there is noise addition that's not
right it's stronger than okay and we'll
focus on this left-hand side of the of
the of the table okay I mean you could
ask a lot of interesting questions about
this table yeah and then we also used
the text from a paper by fancy settle
where they say we define chickening out
of than occurring when an analyst
correctly makes a statement of the form
there's exactly one user that has these
attributes and in the paper they claimed
that they negotiated with the French I
mean that's my understanding of direct
line of the paper that negotiated with
the French their protection authority
and that they approve these these
interpretations of the
wait is this article this document
carries no legal weight and the
important is I think the text that I had
before and this just for us it was an
interesting starting point for thinking
about this that seems to - it is it was
also our understanding of the text
written in the article 29 document and
this is why I'm I'm giving them credit
for for for this sort of the legal
weight of I mean it's probably much more
complicated by that and this I shouldn't
answer this this is going to be part of
a legal analysis that needs to be done -
to go with the technical now see the
table to speak about here but this is
certainly a good question one thing is
that we I think in Europe price what
would several lawyers and I got very
different answers with respect to the
standing of this document because it's
the document that was written before the
gdpr took before before the gdpr so this
and some say that this document is still
relevant in interpreting the concept
from the GDP and some say that's not
there's definitely an interesting legal
question there but I will work as if we
can work out of this text yeah
[Music]
that's a great question so you could ask
you sir why did the Europeans care about
singling out were like in most of the
u.s. standards they speak about
identification okay and I think this is
an interesting progress because many of
the attacks the rear dentition attacks
signaling out was an important stepping
stone towards rare identification and I
think it makes sense to say even if
there if there is a way to single
somebody out this may lead in the future
to reagent occation but again I'm not
privy to what they thought you know were
the reasons for including this but I
think it's an interesting step beyond
just saying very identification I didn't
say that I think the word identifying is
extremely pragmatic we're working on
singing out one reason is that this was
a place where we felt we could make some
progress whereas with some of the other
concepts we are still stuck with making
first steps so it's just it may be just
a mere matter of that that this is this
is the concept that we feel we made some
progress with respect them that's that's
it it doesn't mean that's the most
important one even okay so so let me
give an example for our interpretation
so in particular I just remember that
you don't need a name - don't you need a
name - singing out like you just want to
say here the unique combination that
singles out now to to to explain our
interpretation let's take this fake
Netflix price data example
here we have three users and the movies
that they've seen the dates and so on
there is exactly one role in this
underlying data that contains the movie
distinct which one the third one there
is exactly one row that of a person who
watched Moulin between February 19th and
March 10 okay and and you see that we
don't specify exact date here but this
still singles out somebody in this table
and there is the exactly one row that
does not satisfy any of these two
previous conditions okay and all these
three descriptions single out rows in in
this data set so let's try to define
what the regular government when they
said singling out and I'll think about
it there are set X that is of size n
that is drawn iid from some underlying
distribution okay
ideally I'd like to remove the iid
distribution assumption but we don't
know how to yet maybe there is a way to
do that this data set is fed into an
elimination mechanism and animation
mechanism publishes some data why okay
so maybe aggregate or table or something
like that and then the singling out
adversary gets ahold of this published
data and tries to single out the data
set okay it could also be that the
mechanism is interactive but just for
simplicity I'm going to forget about it
just for this current presentation the
signaling out adversary then outputs a
description or what we call in
mathematical language a predicate okay
this is a condition on possible rows of
the data set like the three examples
that I gave before and then the
adversary's goal is given this published
data that is supposed to preserve
privacy on
nimma t2 output a predicate that matches
exactly one role in the underlying
there's ethics okay and so the
absolutely wants to isolate the person
who's ever said and his first attempt
definition M desalinization mechanism
secure again singing out if no adversary
can isolate a role except for negligible
probability negligible means there is
technical definition for that but let's
say it's very small less than one in a
million
okay and this is a very intuitive
definition and actually we did have a
meeting with people from unlike relevant
people in Europe and we were reading
this definition there were there seem to
to to like it except there's only one
problem that this is impossible to do
okay and why is this impossible to do
okay because there exists a trivial
adversary the turbulence are does not
get to see anything about the dataset
okay so we eliminated the mechanism
eliminate the output and the trivial
address arendelle tries to output a
predicate that isolate a row in that
dataset okay and interestingly this is
possible to do if they adversary can
choose the predicate that matches about
one over N of the universe one like that
is correct for a randomly chosen person
weight probability 1 over n that trivial
calculation shows that this adversary
who did not get any access to the data
succeed with probability 35% okay what
high probability
this wasn't invited question on okay and
so this says that the other story can
always answer it admit that so I can
always answer a single out without even
seeing why but very high probability 37%
okay and if they obviously get that fact
if the answer story gets a feedback
water he succeeded or not then this
probability will rise to 300% very
easily and just repeat it until the
adversary succeeds after three trials on
average the other serve will succeed now
just to make this concrete if the math
is not familiar to you like here's an
example if if this therapist X contains
360 information about 365 people okay
and let's say that these are random
people taken from then the predicate
saying date of birth is October 23rd
matches 1 over 365 portion of the
universe
ok birth date and hence if they
adversary outputs that he can isolate
with probability very 7% so it's really
trivial to do now to your question right
actually in in this example that looked
as if I needed the adversary to know the
underlying distribution but using tools
from randomness extrusion particular the
leftover hash lemma one can create this
predicate without needing to know the
other line distribution assuming that
has sufficient mean entropy doesn't have
to have much some logarithmic in n so
it's the answer is no the opposite does
not need to know almost anything about
an underlying distribution
I'm jumping now over a few steps and
simplifying but here's an idea after
observing this impossibility and so
bringing some technical wisdom into into
the thinking we can try now to nudge
this definition as little as possible
because we don't want to if we started
with the legal text we want to be as
close to it as possible but we can
modify the definition by saying that the
adversary man manages to single out if
the adversary matches if it outputs a
predicate that matches exactly one all
row in the data set but also the dis
predicate has a weight that is bounded
away from one over n okay so we're not
running into this to reality and the
benefit of having this definition is
that such a definition is then now we
have something a formal definition we
can actually do the comparison with
caralluma T or with the fascial privacy
and prove theorems and let me I will not
get over the details but with geometry
we can show quite a general result that
for typical Karen in anonymizes okay you
can signal out non-trivial e so with the
with with the predicate that has a
weight bounded away from one over n with
high probability with this theory 70
percent probability and for the fascial
privacy we can prove the differential
property protects against this notion of
singling out and it establishes also
interesting connections with ideas like
generalization of intersection
properties of differential privacy so
one benefit is I feel we understand
taking out a little better now than then
we did before
you could ask what a differential
privacy dismissive differential privacy
provides an organization under the GDP
and I would be very careful and say this
is unclear it requires more research
singling out was only given as an exam
and the wedding singing lout is
necessary but probably not sufficient so
certainly we need to do more work there
and going back to this table from the
article 29 working party document we now
can say we disagree where this may be
very intuitive determination that
calamity satisfies this requirement for
singling out and actually our analysis
shows that calamity gives an adversary
does most of the work for an adversary
in order to single out okay the
adversary only needs to do something
trivial combat and combine what he gets
from the key anonymizer with a trivial
predicate and he manages to single out
words with respect to differential
privacy our notion the notion that
represent forcing aloud which may not be
as strong as as needed is satisfied by
differential privacy I say may not be as
strong as needed because we made in
particular we made this assumption that
data is IAD from some underlying
distribution is this notion I took a lot
of time talking about when our privacy
concepts the good concept is this a good
concept okay
and I say partially it is useful for
examining this logical imitation
concepts like differential privacy
limited with respect to the legal
requirements I think but then and it's
resilient to post-processing but we can
prove that doesn't self composed okay
and as I mentioned I think composition
is a crucial crucial property for good
privacy concept
so I got to slide this 298th s so this
is not a summary so we spoke about
Foundation Ric the rigorous approach to
data privacy and this had led to new
concepts and rich theory and initial
steps of real-life deployment we saw the
positive side of negative thinking I
think I spoke about that in a lot and I
also spoke about the growing
relationship between theoretical
computer science and scholarship that
maybe only 10 years ago we we would
think are no outside the reach of
theoretical computer science like legal
and ethical scholarship and I think this
is a I look at this as like a a great
sign of maturation for our field that
were doing that we're taking
responsibility and have one more slide
and this is a completely different
direction from everything I've said so
far or maybe not where are we heading at
and and again here I think my main my
main goal is to think about establishing
a working group throughout the semester
so personal information is collected and
controlled by industry in government at
a never-before manageable extent and
differential privacy he said it may may
be the story that I told you know sounds
like a pink nice story about how we
conquered privacy how it rose from the
ashes whatever but is this a real
improvement or is it this fig leaf for
for this organization so I don't have a
good answer for that in particular you
could ask what the differential privacy
is currently used as it
to keep the power in the hands of the
data holders because if you think even
if we think about the current
implementations that use the local model
and require a massive participation in
order to get utility then this seems to
fit here ok so we can ask whether this
imbalance between industry individuals
being mitigated and katrina is going to
talk about some thoughts that we've
started the assembling together and when
are you talking
on Thursday and about the research
agenda around a topic that we call their
coops and I think there is a lot of
theory there would be a lot of theory to
think about and develop there and maybe
a last question in this not that
positive direction is what if privacy is
already completely lost and I don't
think it's a ridiculous question anymore
can we understand what functions privacy
had and restore them using other tools
and I think this audience because we
have spent so much work in understanding
analyzing privacy rigorously is best
positioned to try to begin thinking
about this and answering this question
if we love privacy can we get the
functions that privacy gave us using
other tools and I think here would its
positive tone I will out finish
for a couple of questions
tickle like
you tell me what do you mean by privacy
just can you be a little more concrete
about the privacy being a couple you
lost already for 40 out there or the
information that may be I mean there
also be there is so more information to
be generated definitely a lot more
information to be generated yeah I think
certainly for the information that was
that is being collected was a bit
misleading okay this is being humble and
collected and used like as we speak and
certainly about the past there's this
question whether we lost control there
and whether and it could be that that
information is already sufficient for
for us to feel that you know the
benefits that we got from privacy in the
past they're the reasons that a notion
like privacy exists that this is already
broken and I did not want to - I have a
few ideas on like how do we think about
privacy and like the the benefit that
privacy gave us not letting it like one
idea is to say but privacy is a tool for
reducing complexity in everyday life
when you go to your doctor you don't
need to think or strategize about the
information that you're giving where
you're in interpersonal relationship you
don't need to strategize about the
information that you're giving or you
need to like to make less complicated
decisions with respect to it compared
the wood with a case where you don't
have privacy so one question could be
whether if we are losing this tool as a
tool for reducing complexity in making
decisions in everyday life can we
replace it with another tool that will
help us do something similar reduce
the complexity of making these decisions
a question about formalizing legal
notions given that at least in common
law legal notions exist both sort of in
statutes and regulations has written
though certainly the aspect you were
talking about but also kind of there was
this living and evolving notion of
various concepts embodied in you know
precedent yeah it sort of practice the
way it's actually used and so I wonder
if there's any hope or what would what
are the challenges beyond it tribulus
ones of formalizing these I'm sure
there's a term for these kind of
constantly evolving first let me say
that is Alex here Alex is here so we've
many questions about the legal work need
to be addressed to Alex but one thing
that definitely I observed as who worked
is that we wish we had that present
present precedence and that we could use
that as information in our legal
analysis as you see the legal case is
very thin in mostly and interpretation
coming from courts could be very useful
to us unfortunately as far as I know
this hasn't been litigated in with
respect to the questions that were are
interested in and so I think at first
place this is going to be very
interesting to say how courts think
about these questions when they need to
whether brought to them I also hope that
some of the reasoning that we suggest
will be useful for the courts in
thinking about this because we're
bringing tools from mathematics that
usually in court so not I'm not using
but yeah I think that's going to be very
interesting to see how first to see
courts deal with these tough questions
and then whether they what we're saying
makes sense to the court or in what ways
we can translate the language that we're
using to the language that they that
they can operate on giving you an answer
I guess but so that where specific
information needs to be acted upon now I
would argue that most of the information
collective especially but at least by
tech companies is intended to be acted
upon you know to be recommend to
recommend something or deserve an ad or
something like that do you see do you
think that DP is just a fundamentally C
compatible paradigm with protecting
privacy in that kind of setting
important you think you know there could
be specific variants of it it could be
adjusted to that or what are your
thoughts kind of one yeah so I think
it's it's certainly realistic to think
about differential privacy giving
answers to a portion of the privacy
problem okay and that is why it was
important for me to give that slide
first you realize that yeah we're not we
haven't solved the entire
privacy problem we managed to carve out
a significant portion of it and deal
with it very successfully I believe but
it doesn't mean that we have theory for
the entire privacy problem maybe in some
cases differential privacy would be
applicable when when you operate on a
person's data but I think it will be
quite special cases essentially what the
fascial privacy says that you are going
to get the same treatment what I'm using
your data or not okay
and that seems contradictory to to that
so only in cases were
it's not contradictory to this statement
we could use differential privacy and I
think we are missing an understanding of
what is a concept of privacy that is
applicable in the case of when we
operate on individual information when
you are shown an ad when you click on an
ad things like that it's not true to me
people do speak about privacy in this
context but very informally it's not
clear to me how to capture it in the way
that we can data needs to be made public
facing or needs to be made visible to
the comma so if the company doesn't
actually need to see maybe it's possible
to give us a parent is I mean I think
it's worth thinking hard about who
actually needs access to what so if
we're talking about questions like that
you know companies showing me ads
without a company learning my
information there are definitely tools
in Quito graffia they're suited for for
doing that
I think the privacy question comes to
life and becomes more interesting when
at the end of this chain the individual
is going to operate in the public maybe
based on on things that happen there are
them in so even if all this chain was
invisible to the public the fact that
the outcome is makes the entire make you
makes you makes it important to ask what
is happening throughout this chain and
how that affects privacy
so it wasn't my token because of time it
did not get to the final cut definitely
I think like the question of how crypto
and differential privacy in tried is a
fascinating one we don't have enough
work done in this direction we have some
work done in this direction extremely
strict and it could be the determination
there could be more relaxed yeah so has
there has been work definitely in the
area of like commanding the pressure
privacy and security party computation
yeah so what we're missing I think like
like in the centralized model for
instance differences obviously does
crypto help there and we have very
little understanding of off of this
question
you're eating into your own so
definitely this is a very good example
like you we could deliver the movie with
a casual privacy but do billing would
sorry we crypto but do the billing with
differential privacy for instance that
would be an interesting combination of
the two okay thank you
[Applause]